I sent in a secret diner let's watch it
shall we
my 30 dinars love Laika hikes rustic
charm but a service and food suffers
from John Michele's lack of leadership
in the kitchen are things running more
smoothly now
when I was between the kitchen are we
not allowed to have that on in the
morning to give the rest of nice and
cool when butter starts melting on the
table are you cutting back on the
electricity bill just forget the pretty
done or it's a bit of a schoolboy error
when we can't have the air conditioning
on
well shame
is it too late to cry just have new
potatoes these artists writers don't
boiled new places okay thank you
beans are delicious and I think white
shape into it is that yeah that's okay
okay yeah thank you
place them potatoes finest I'm talking
about the horrible greasy set of
potatoes that came out swimming in fat
they look dreadful in the kitchen we
have to be you need to be more to watch
ever than yeah you can't do everything
don't you everything no you can't but
when you cook a funny main course the
garnish is he can support us it boils
down to the consistency again doesn't it
what a shame so anyone could take these
in a doggie bag not the ice cream
obviously cuz I just think we're not
gonna make their flight in time
otherwise sorry that's my fault
okay thank you very much Blaine
padeen oh we're in a rush now we're
ready to go waiting for her to come take
the money she's answer the phone she's
gone on to the kitchen she still hasn't
come to take the money
well the shame right at the very end
dying to catch the flight it's an urgent
request and it's just being blamele
ignored so it was like some of small
little niggling facts that you put them
all together it's like a bit of a blow
par performance when I know when that
rations on song it's the best bistro in
the country
in a way I'm disappointed by the the
potato saga that does something that's a
lack of concentration a lack of
supervision with the service testing we
can change cooking the potatoes the
communication with the chef's of this
kind of thing can easily be resolved